House of the Dragon Episode 5 has a royal
wedding.
So naturally, there’s politics, drama, and
a murder.
What happens, and what does it mean?
This video has no spoilers for Hot D beyond
Episode 5.
The opening sequence is a symbolic family
tree showing the bloodline of House Targaryen.
And it’s slightly changed across episodes.
The symbol for Alicent Hightower now has a
bloodline connecting to her husband King Viserys,
and there are two bloodlines coming from her
– representing her son Aegon and her daughter
Helaena.
The symbol for Rhaenyra now connects to Laenor
Velaryon, who she marries in this episode.
In the previous episode, Viserys told Daemon
to go back to his wife in the Vale.
So now, in the Vale, we meet Daemon’s estranged
wife Rhea Royce.
House Royce is famous for their ancient bronze
armour engraved with runes of the First Men.
So Rhea’s clothes are decorated with runes
– which the show’s creators copied from
Wikipedia.
The Royce bronze armour, and their history
as Bronze Kings, is why Daemon calls Rhea
his “bronze bitch”.
In Game of Thrones, House Royce is led by
Bronze Yohn Royce.
He’s the father of Waymar Royce, who gets
killed by white walkers in Episode 1.
The Royce castle is Runestone – just up
the coast from King’s Landing.
So Daemon arrives and finds Rhea.
And Rhea is immediately suspicious of him,
glancing over her shoulder.
She insults Daemon, saying he should have
sex with a sheep.
Cause previously, Daemon said that in the
Vale the sheep are prettier than the women.
Rhea mocks Daemon, saying that Viserys rejected
Daemon by making Rhaenyra heir to the Throne
instead of him.
And Rhea says that her marriage to Daemon
is still unconsummated – they’ve never
had sex.
Rhea says Daemon “couldn't finish”.
And we know Daemon has history of sexual dysfunction,
of not being able to have sex with Mysaria
and Rhaenyra.
So Rhea really knows how to hurt Daemon’s
insecurities about sex and family.
She’s just as sharp-tongued as he is, so
it’s easy to see how Rhea and Daemon’s
personalities clashed, and the marriage failed.
Daemon comes close, Rhea grabs her bow, her
horse rears up, Daemon touches it(?) and it
falls, so that Rhea is crushed, paralysing
her.
Then Daemon kills her with a rock – to make
it look like she died by accident, falling
off her horse.
The books say that Rhea died in a “tragic
mishap”, falling and cracking her head on
a rock.
Daemon was on the Stepstones at the time,
so in the books Rhea’s death may have been
an accident.
In the show, it is ambiguous whether Daemon
came here planning to kill Rhea, or if he
just took the opportunity, but he kills his
hated wife.
Which means Daemon is now free to remarry
whether for love, or for lust, or for power.
Otto Hightower leaves King’s Landing.
Viserys fired Otto as Hand of the King, because
Otto had manipulated Viserys, and undermined
Rhaenyra to try and make Otto’s grandson
Aegon heir to the Throne.
Otto blames his daughter Alicent for getting
him fired, because Alicent sided with Rhaenyra,
and said Rhaenyra was innocent of having sex
with Daemon.
But Otto says Rhaenyra is her enemy.
Cause if Rhaenyra takes the Throne after Viserys
died, there’ll be “war” – many lords
won’t accept a female ruler, and would prefer
Alicent’s son Aegon on the Throne.
Otto says Rhaenyra will need to kill Alicent’s
children, because they’re a threat to her
claim.
Otto says they must beat Rhaenyra and get
Aegon on the Throne.
They must win the game of thrones, or die.
Otto loves Alicent and wants to protect her,
but Alicent’s only in this dangerous situation
because Otto pushed Alicent to marry Viserys,
and pushed for Aegon to be heir.
Alicent went along with her family’s ambitions,
and now she and her children are in danger.
Larys Strong, the Clubfoot, is the son of
Lyonel Strong, and the brother of Harwin Strong.
Larys tells Alicent – subtly and indirectly
– that Maester Mellos gave Rhaenyra moon
tea – hinting that Rhaenyra lied to Alicent,
and she really did have sex.
Larys says Alicent can’t rely on Rhaenyra,
and that Larys will be Alicent’s ally.
So Larys creates conflict, turning Alicent
against Rhaenyra, and positions himself up
as a friend to the queen.
It’s similar to how Littlefinger in Game
of Thrones creates chaos, to gain power.
But how does Larys know about Rhaenyra’s
moon tea?
Larys says that he’s just observant – we
saw him listening to the ladies at the hunt.
But maybe he also has spies like Mysaria’s
little birds.
Maybe he knows the secrets of the Red Keep
like Daemon.
Maybe he’s working with the maesters – Larys’
dad Lyonel did study at the Citadel.
Or maybe Larys’ knowledge is magical.
YouTuber JoeMagician argues that Larys might
be a greenseer.
Greenseers are people like Bran and Bloodraven
who use the magic of the old gods and the
weirwood trees.
Greenseers can see through the eyes of weirwoods,
and see through the eyes of animals, can see
through time and space.
Greenseers have the blood of the First Men,
the original humans in Westeros – that includes
House Stark like Bran, and House Blackwood
like Bloodraven, and House Strong like Larys
– he also descends from First Men.
Bloodraven says that greenseers have powerful
minds but are physically weak, just like Larys
is weak with his club foot.
So it is plausible that Larys could be a greenseer.
House Strong is based at Harrenhal, and Harrenhal
just happens to be right next door to the
Isle of Faces, a mysterious island sacred
to the old gods.
The isle has a grove of weirwood trees, watched
over by the mystical green men.
Maybe the curious Larys Strong visited the
Isle of Faces, and learned magic from the
green men.
Maybe he can skinchange into animals.
In the books, Bloodraven was once a spymaster
who skinchanged into crows to spy on people.
In the books, Arya Stark also has this power,
and she skinchanges into a cat to spy on people.
So maybe Larys skinchanges into these rats
we’ve seen in Hot D, using them to spy and
listen to conversations in the Red Keep.
And he could see through this weirwood to
witness all the important conversations that
happen here.
This scene with Alicent visually connects
Larys with the weirwood – at first it seems
almost like Larys’ voice is coming from
the tree, like he’s watching through its
eyes.
For more on this theory, check out JoeMagician.
But so far we don’t know for sure how Larys
knows what he knows.
But he is a mysterious and powerful character,
and in a way he’s similar to Alicent.
Cause Larys talks about a flower from Braavos
that isn’t native to King’s Landing, but
still thrives here.
Just like Larys and Alicent aren’t native
to the Red Keep, they aren’t royal Targaryens,
but they may still thrive and grow strong
here.
In the background, there’s an image of a
lemon tree.
Which might be a subtle hint to a mystery
in the books.
In the books, Daenerys remembers she once
lived in a house in Braavos with a lemon tree
outside.
Which is weird, because the books also say
that lemon trees don’t grow in Braavos,
they only grow in warmer climates to the south.
It’s not native – like Larys’ flower.
Some fans speculate that Daenerys’ house
with the lemon tree was actually in Dorne
for the Martell conspiracy.
Viserys and Rhaenyra sail to Driftmark, the
island of House Velaryon.
Viserys gets seasick and pukes, so his new
Hand of the King, Lyonel Strong, gives him
a cloth to wipe the vomit.
In Game of Thrones, Jaime says “The king
shits and the Hand wipes”.
It’s the job of the Hand of the King to
solve the king’s problems and clean up his
mess.
It’s interesting that Viserys takes this
miserable boat journey instead of just flying
a dragon.
Viserys doesn’t have his own dragon anymore,
but he could’ve hitched a ride on Rhaenyra’s
dragon Syrax.
We’ve seen dragons used as passenger vehicles
before.
Like they’re a big scaly flying minibus.
Maybe Viserys is afraid to ride dragons, he
said they’re an uncontrollable dangerous
power.
They arrive at the Velaryon castle, High Tide.
The Velaryons originally lived in a smaller
castle, but after Corlys made heaps of money
on his voyages, he built this newer better
castle.
High Tide is on its own small tidal island,
that’s only accessible by foot when the
tide is low.
Showing the Velaryon connection to sea power
and ships.
Lyonel is offended that that the Velaryons
don’t greet King Viserys outside.
It’s meant to be a big deal when the king
visits your home, like when King Robert visits
the Starks in Game of Thrones.
But Viserys is just greeted by Laena Velaryon,
the daughter of Corlys and Rhaenys.
Previously, Viserys rejected Laena’s marriage
proposal.
So now sending Laena to meet Viserys is a
reminder of how insulted Corlys felt that
his family was a denied a royal marriage.
Corlys meets Viserys inside, seated on his
Driftwood Throne.
According to ancient legend, this Throne was
given to the Velaryons by the Merling King,
a kind of mermaid sea god.
It’s a total power move that Corlys has
the king come to him, and Corlys stands over
Viserys.
Corlys is a very proud man who wants everyone
to know how great he is.
This room is called the Hall of Nine – it’s
full of treasures and trophies that Corlys
got on his famous nine sea voyages.
There’s a “snake orrery”, and a hanging
city, a giant sea shell.
And now Corlys adds the Crabfeeder’s mask
to his collection.
Corlys has achieved so much that he lives
in a museum of his own awesomeness, and yet
Corlys is still not satisfied.
Viserys proposes for his daughter and heir
Rhaenyra to marry Corlys’ son Laenor.
He says this will finally unite the Targaryen
and Velaryons.
Which is funny, cause Corlys Velaryon’s
wife Rhaenys Targaryen is standing right there.
But Corlys is still angry that Rhaenys didn’t
inherit the Throne back at the Harrenhal Council.
The marriage of Rhaenyra and Laenor is really
about making up for that rejection and finally
marrying a Velaryon into the royal line.
Corlys negotiates the details – like, traditionally,
children have their father’s family name.
So will Rhaenyra and Laenor’s children,
the next rulers of Westeros, be called Velaryon?
Viserys doesn’t want to the Targaryen royal
name to end with this marriage.
So he says that Rhaenyra and Laenor’s children
will be called Velaryon, but when one inherits
the Throne, they’ll be called Targaryen
to continue the Targaryen dynasty.
So both Viserys and Corlys are very concerned
with their legacy and pride.
Viserys may also be thinking of Aegon the
Conqueror’s dream, that a Targaryen will
defeat the white walkers.
But they agree to the marriage, forging a
stronger alliance between the last two Valyrian
dragonriding families.
Meanwhile, Rhaenyra and Laenor make their
own agreement.
Laenor is gay – Joffrey Lonmouth is his
boyfriend.
So marrying Rhaenyra is not what either of
them want.
Corlys says that Laenor will grow out of being
gay.
But Rhaenyra accepts Laenor’s sexuality
– she uses an analogy that some people like
duck and some people like goose.
This is based on a line in the books where
Mellos says it doesn’t matter that Laenor
is gay, he should marry Rhaenyra anyway, because
Mellos doesn’t like fish, but when fish
is served he’ll eat it anyway.
Rhaenyra and Laenor agree that they’ll do
their duty, get married, make some babies,
but on the side they’ll hook up with who
they want – Laenor can stay with Joffrey,
and Rhaenyra can have Criston or whoever else
she wants.
Rhaenyra must’ve been inspired earlier by
Daemon saying you can have sex outside your
marriage.
Rhaenyra and Laenor are both happy with this
compromise, but polyamorous relationships
can cause drama especially if combined with
secrecy, politics and dragons.
Rhaenys says this marriage puts her son Laenor
in danger.
Like Otto, she says there will be conflict
between Rhaenyra and Aegon for the Throne.
Corlys says he’s will to fight to put a
Velaryon’s child on the Throne.
He says it’s justice, to make up for Rhaenys
not getting the Throne.
But Rhaenys she’s over that, she cares more
about her family’s safety than she cares
for the Throne.
She suggests Corlys is really motivated not
by justice, but by pride and power.
Despite her fears, she’s dragged along with
Corlys’ ambitions, like Aemma with Viserys,
and Alicent with Otto.
Criston feels guilty and ashamed that he broke
his Kingsguard oath by having sex with Rhaenyra.
So Criston asks Rhaenyra to run away with
him to the east.
To escape their responsibilities as Kingsguard
and princess, and to be free and married together.
Rhaenyra has said before that she wants to
escape her responsibilities and wants to travel
the east.
But lately, Rhaenyra has accepted her political
duties.
Viserys told her about Aegon the Conqueror’s
dream that the Targaryen dynasty must protect
the world from the white walkers, and made
her promise to uphold this.
So Rhaenyra says she’ll stay.
Buut she could still keep Criston as a lover
on the side.
Criston is insulted by this, he doesn’t
want to be a “whore”, used for sex.
Which seems hypocritical – Criston expects
Rhaenyra to give up her crown and her family
and her home, but Criston is too proud himself
to be a paramour?
But it goes deeper.
Because Criston’s whole identity, his greatest
achievement, is being a Kingsguard.
He swore a sacred oath of chastity, to not
have sex.
And he can’t live in that white cloak knowing
it’s a lie, knowing he could be killed for
his crime.
He sees running to the east as a way to escape
that shame, and marrying Rhaenyra as way to
fix his sin.
Running east is not a great idea, but it’s
the only idea he has.
So when Rhaenyra says no, Criston loses his
one hope for a tolerable life.
After speaking with Larys, Alicent suspects
that Rhaenyra lied, that maybe she did have
sex with Daemon.
So Alicent questions Rhaenyra’s guard Criston
– though, like Otto, Alicent is too proper
and ashamed to directly say that she thinks
Rhaenyra and Daemon had sex.
So Criston thinks Alicent is talking about
Rhaenyra having sex with him.
Criston is so full of shame and fear, so desperate
for repentance that he confesses, and tells
Alicent he had sex with Rhaenyra.
He asks to be put to death, rather than gelded
or tortured.
Cause when the Kingsguard Lucamore Strong
had sex, they cut off his penis and sent him
to the Wall.
And when the Kingsguard Terrence Toyne has
sex, the king has him cut to pieces slowly.
Criston wants a quick honourable end.
But Alicent doesn’t give him punishment
or absolution.
She’s so stunned that she just lets him
go, leaving Criston to sink deeper into guilt
and fear, knowing he could be killed for his
crime at any time.
Alicent is angry not just that Rhaenyra lied
to her about not having sex, but also cause
Alicent believing Rhaenyra is part of what
got her dad Otto fired.
If she can’t trust Rhaenyra, and Otto is
gone, Alicent is more alone than ever.
King Viserys is very sick from the infection
that started in his hand.
Viserys’ actor said he’s now got something
like leprosy, deteriorating his body and bones.
Which is partly a metaphor for his stress
and his failure as a king.
Grand Maester Mellos treats Viserys with leeches.
A new maester called Orwyle says a different
treatment might work better, but Mellos refuses..
Which is suspicious.
Mellos talks as though his treatments are
working, but they’re not..
This started with a cut, and now the king’s
falling to pieces, yet Mellos refuses to try
different treatments that might help.
So some fans speculate that Mellos is deliberately
letting the king die, maybe in conspiracy
with Otto and the Hightowers.
They might hope that if Viserys is weak or
dead they can more easily get Aegon on the
Throne.
Viserys knows he might die soon.
So he thinks on his legacy, and wonders if
he’d be remembered more if he had fought
battles.
His model city of Valyria is behind Viserys
– the empire of his ancestors is on his
mind.
But Lyonel says it’s a good thing that Viserys’
reign was peaceful – he continued the peaceful
legacy of his grandfather King Jaehaerys.
But Viserys has an ego, and knows that they
don’t sing songs for kings of peace.
The Velaryons come to King’s Landing for
the wedding.
And for the first time, we see Rhaenys’
dragon, called Meleys, “the Red Queen”.
Meleys is a “magnificent scarlet she-dragon”.
She was first ridden by Alyssa Targaryen,
the mother of Viserys and Daemon.
And Meleys was once the fastest dragon in
Westeros.
The other dragon here is Seasmoke, Laenor’s
dragon.
Inside, Lord Jason Lannister arrives with
his twin brother Tyland.
Jason makes a dumb women joke, and Rhaenyra
is not impressed.
The Velaryons arrive in rich clothing showing
off their wealth.
And then, just as Viserys is about to speak,
Daemon bloody Targaryen saunters in as though
he owns the place.
Just last episode, Viserys told Daemon to
never return.
But now Viserys just lets Daemon return from
exile for the second time.
Viserys seems incapable of saying no to his
family – and since his brother daughter
and wife all want different things, this is
a recipe for conflict.
When Viserys starts his speech, he’s interrupted
again by the arrival of Alicent in a brilliant
green dress.
Earlier, Alicent felt alone and betrayed,
so now she rises definitely and asserts her
own power as queen.
Green is a Hightower colour – Larys says
that the Hightower beacon burns green at times
of war.
So this is a rallying call for the Hightowers
to stand by her.
Previously, Alicent wore red Targaryen clothes,
so now wearing green sets her apart from and
against Rhaenyra.
Previously, Rhaenyra called Alicent “sister”,
cause they were close like equals.
But now, Alicent calls Rhaenyra “stepdaughter”,
setting herself above Rhaenyra.
Green is a colour of envy – the director
said that Alicent had always been envious
of Rhaenyra’s freedom while Alicent felt
trapped in her duty.
Alicent has always been a proper lady – so
she shows her power not with swords or dragons,
but with a dress, armouring herself in feminine
fashion.
Her uncle, Lord Hobert Hightower, tells Alicent
that Oldtown stands with her.
So the battle lines are being drawn.
If there’s conflict for the Throne between
Alicent’s son Aegon and Rhaenyra, it looks
like the Hightowers will support Aegon, while
the Velaryons will support Rhaenyra and Laenor.
And all this tension is evident at the wedding.
Rhaenyra and Laenor perform a dance that looks
like some.. dragon mating ritual with flapping
wings – maybe this is an ancient Valyrian
dance.
Rhaenyra’s actor said they called one of
these dance moves the “smelly fart”.
Laenor says dancing is like combat.
In the books, there’s a war called the Dance
of the Dragons – dancing being a metaphor
for the deadly motion of politics and violence.
So as the guests join the flowing movements
of this the dance, emotions and ambitions
swirl amongst them.
Daemon looks hungrily at Rhaenyra.
Alicent glares in green.
Criston boils with jealousy and shame.
And there are closeups of meat being cut with
knives – foreshadowing bloody violence.
According to interviews, this drummer is Mushroom
– Mushroom is the dwarf jester who tells
tales of sex and murder in the book Fire & Blood.
Gerold Royce confronts Daemon, and accuses
him of murdering Rhea Royce.
Daemon acts like he doesn’t care.
And says that since Rhea was the heir to Runestone,
but Rhea had no kids, Daemon will claim the
lordship of Runestone for himself.
He says he’ll talk to the Lady of the Vale,
Jeyne Arryn, about it.
And Gerold is shocked – maybe Gerold wants
to inherit Runestone himself, since he was
Rhea’s cousin.
So maybe Daemon’s implication here is that
if Gerold shuts up about Daemon killing Rhea,
Daemon will let Gerold have Runestone – but
if Gerold pushes his accusation, Daemon will
take Runestone to fuck with Gerold.
And it seems to work – Gerold backs off.
Daemon flirts with Laena Velaryon.
Daemon seems helplessly attracted to women
with Valyrian blood and silver hair.
Maybe because Valyrian women can birth Valyrian
children who can ride dragons – having dragonriders
as children could be a way for Daemon to gain
power.
Though last we heard, Laena was to be betrothed
to the son of the Sealord of Braavos, so she
might not be single.
After Laena, Daemon flirts with the next Valyrian
blonde, his niece, the bride, Rhaenyra.
And Rhaenyra flirts back, saying sarcastically
but >actually kind of for real though< that
Daemon should take her and marry her.
Rhaenyra is still attracted to Daemon, and
has desires that Laenor won’t satisfy.
Laenor’s boyfriend Joffrey figures out that
Criston is Rhaenyra’s secret lover – he
can tell by how Criston watches Rhaenyra.
So Joffrey tells Criston that he knows Criston’s
secret.
He says that together they can protect both
their secret affairs – Joffrey’s affair
with Laenor, and Criston’s with Rhaenyra.
You can read this as a threat – like, Criston
better keep Joffrey and Laenor’s affair
secret, or else Joffrey will expose Criston’s
secret affair.
But while Joffrey is fairly relaxed about
these secrets, Criston is a ticking time bomb
of pent up resentment, shame and suicidal
rage.
Full of emotion, and scared that Joffrey will
blab his secret, Criston snaps, starts a fight,
he punches Laenor, there’s chaos.
So Lyonel sends his son Harwin in to get the
princess to safety.
Harwin “Breakbones” is said to be the
strongest knight in Westeros, so if you need
muscle, he’s your guy.
In the fight, Criston’s emotions pour out
as he beats Joffrey to death.
When we first met Criston, he seemed like
a fairytale noble white knight.
But beneath that superficial appearance, Criston
is a brutal killer who makes his feelings
and bad decisions everyone else’s problem.
The show’s creators describe Criston as
a “thug”.
And his violence was only made worse by his
knighthood.
Knights are expected to defend their honour
with violence.
A Kingsguard is taught that sex is wrong,
but killing is fine.
The books often explore how knighthood and
honour culture empower bad men to hurt innocent
people.
In the books, Criston kills Joffrey not at
a wedding, but at a tournament while fighting
in a melee – which is a less terrible crime.
Deaths do happen at tournaments – like those
knights in Episode 1.
But beating a man to death at a royal wedding,
and punching the future king consort in the
face, are very serious crimes.
But somehow Criston escapes the wedding and
goes to the godswood.
He can’t imagine any honourable life for
himself, so he prepares to commit suicide.
But he’s stopped by Alicent.
Alicent needs allies.
Criston needs purpose.
And both these guys are angry at Rhaenyra.
So maybe they’ll make an alliance, and Queen
Alicent might protect Criston from punishment
for his murder.
After the Joffrey’s death, the planned celebrations
are cancelled.
Rhaenyra and Laenor are hastily married, as
Laenor sobs for his dead lover.
In the books, Joffrey is comatose for six
days, and Laenor stays by his side until Joffrey
dies.
King Viserys collapses again, and his crown
falls off his head – highlighting that Viserys
may die soon, and that the succession for
his crown is uncertain.
A rat nibbles at Joffrey’s blood, which
could represent Larys, whose words to Alicent
fed this conflict.
The rat could also represent all the lords
and knights who are eager to fight for power
– like crows feasting on the corpse of House
Targaryen.
Everyone feels that war is coming, and they
can almost taste the blood.
If you want to know more about the magic of
the old gods, about Bran and Bloodraven, and
Arya skinchanging a cat – you’ve gotta
check out the Game of Thrones books.
The main series has Bran and Arya’s magic.
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms features Bloodraven’s
past life as a spymaster.
The World of Ice and Fire is full of worldbuilding
and a short summary of House of the Dragon.
And Fire & Blood tells the full story of Hot
D. You can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching, please like and subscribe,
and check out the Alt Shift X podcasts linked
below.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Sakditat
Kwanchaitanya, carrie stier, Maxwell Gierke,
Jerry, Cairo Minott, Laurie Perek, and Thanos
Is god.
Cheers.